So we should think about
the hypothalamus forget,
because it seems to be
pretty damn important.
Consult,
I would say,
you know,
people have wondered sometimes
when they've asked me,
you know,
where's the Super Ego and the ego
and the Ed located in the brain.
And you know,
it's a stupid question and
it's not a stupid question.
At the same time,
um,
it's actually a useful question at one
level of analysis because you could say,
well,
the end from the [inaudible]
perspective is sort of the,
the natural force that propels motivation.
You know,
and,
and it's,
when we say motivation,
we're not saying much
different than saying in,
by the way,
you know,
it's the same kind of low resolution work.
And it's clearly the case that we have
fundamental motivational systems and that
we do share them with animals and
that they do drive our behavior.
But they also drive our perceptions in
all the ways that Freud thought about,
you know,
and one of the things I really like
about the psychoanalysts is that they,
they,
they never make the mistake of assuming
that a motivational system or an
emotional system is a mechanical system
that reacts to deterministically.
They say no,
those things are like personalities.
And that's,
that's much more sophisticated viewpoint
than the typical behaviorist or the
typical cognitive psychologist,
you know,
because they tend to think of the computer
in either stimulus response terms.
So it's basically deterministic
chains or as if the,
the,
the information processing system
is a computational apparatus,
which it is.
But it's not only that,
you know,
it's an embodied computational apparatus
and the body is a very sophisticated
thing.
You know,
it's,
it's been very difficult for
us to build embodied robots.
And it's also the case that
until you build in body robots,
the things don't really get smart,
you know?
Yeah.
You have to have a body for the thing
to actually have any intelligence.
And that was actually figured out by a
robotics engineer named Rodney Brooks
back in the 1990s 92 93 published
a couple of papers on that saying,
you know,
that if we were going to
build artificial intelligence,
we shouldn't start from the top down.
We shouldn't build a
world modeling machine.
And then embedded in
something that moves around,
we should build something that sort
of moves around semi autonomously,
like a stupid insect.
Insects aren't stupid.
So I do mean as stupid insect
and if we could manage that,
we'd really be doing something,
you know,
and I think we've,
we might've gotten beyond
the stupid insect level of,
of robots so far.
Um,
and you know,
it's starting to ramp up really fast,
but it's in large part because
the things are embodied.
And so because it is the case as,
as we've discussed,
that your,
your perceptual,
your cognitive perceptual motor systems
have to be embedded in an output system
that can interact with the world in order
for them to be doing anything that's
actual or real.